SHARON HARRIS: Hello, and
thank you for joining us.
I know it's really
late in the day,
but we're so happy to see
all of your faces here.
My name is Sharon Harris.
I am the VP of
Alliances at Deloitte.
And I oversee our relationship
with the Google Marketing
Platform.
And I am thrilled
today to be joined
by my partner and my
technologist extraordinaire,
Mr. Matt Mager.
MATT MAGER: Hi, I'm Matt Mager.
I'm a Global Partner Solutions
Lead on the Google Marketing
Platform and the Ads products.
SHARON HARRIS: So
today we're going
to share with you how the Google
Cloud Platform and the Google
Marketing Platform
are coming together.
And this is really exciting,
particularly for us marketers,
because it's all about, how can
we leverage this technology?
And today we're
going to look at it
through the lens of a
marketer in the retail space.
Retail is an industry
that's really near and dear
to my heart.
And it's also an
industry that's really
experiencing a ton of
change, a lot of disruption,
and certainly it's under siege.
Whether you're a brick
and mortar store,
whether you're online,
a mom and pop shop,
everyone is really
engaged in the battle
today when it comes to retail.
Using retail as our
focus, we're really
going to showcase the power
of marketing analytics
on the Google Cloud Platform.
And most importantly,
what we now
refer to as cloud for
marketing, so let's get started.
I have this slide for
a couple of reasons.
One, when you think
about it, at least 40%
of the businesses
that we know today
are going to die in
the next 10 years.
It's a very ominous slide.
But I think it's
really important
because it articulates in a
very clear way what's at stake.
I do believe, however, it
does provide an insight
into what we're going
to talk about today,
in that there's still hope.
While we've seen many
of our beloved retailers
fade away, whether it's
Brookstone, or Henry Brindle.
Or we've seen stores close
like Payless, or Gymboree,
or Victoria's Secret,
there's still hope.
One of my favorite
retailers closed, Toys R
Us I was really sad to
see Jeffrey pack his bags,
make that last exit
out of the store
because that was a fond
part of my childhood.
That was just an
iconic brand for me.
Everyone loved Toys R Us.
But this quote
really symbolizes,
this is where we are right now.
And this is really
a critical juncture.
If you're in the
audience, saying
you're working for a retailer
or you're a marketer,
this is really a
pivotal moment today.
Now I've spent over 20 years
in the marketing space--
a variety of different roles.
And I can tell you firsthand.
The job of a marketer is very
difficult. The average CMO,
their tenure is, if they're
lucky, 18 to 24 months,
if you're not showing results.
And those challenges
are continuing to evolve
and there are new concerns,
but there are new opportunities
at every turn.
Top of the list of challenges
is, how do you keep pace
with the technological change?
All of you are here
at Google Cloud Next
because you know what those
next technological changes are
looking like.
And that's really important.
And more and more marketers are
starting to come to the table
and understand how to
leverage that change.
But when you look at
those top five challenges,
we've got other
things to think about.
We've got to think about, how
do we get the right talent
in our organization?
How do we create
engaging digital content?
How do we have the right
skills in our business?
And one of my
favorites is, how do we
measure the effectiveness
of digital content?
As a marketer, I can't
manage what I can't measure
and that's really critical.
And that's where, once again,
the technology can truly
help me.
I was really sad to see
Sears file bankruptcy.
Sears, the original superstore.
The precursor, if you
will, to the Amazon.
Sears, an iconic American brand.
Everything you wanted,
from batteries, to dresses,
to Kenmore appliances, to tires.
Everything.
MATT MAGER: Houses.
SHARON HARRIS: Houses too.
Everything under one roof.
Garanimals, chubby kid clothes.
Everything you could possibly
need under one umbrella.
That was the destination for
the family on the weekends.
If your family was
like mine, Sears,
we got the tires rotated, we
got a new battery, picked up
some clothes, some
fabric even, everything
under that single store.
I was really sad to
see them say farewell
because it seemed to be the end
of a major era in our country.
But I say this
because I do believe
that there is still hope.
And today Matt and I are going
to share with you some things
that we believe will
help you to avoid some
of the pitfalls many of
these other retailers
have experienced.
Now, it goes without saying.
A key issue for a
marketer today is trust.
Consumer trust is paramount.
We've all heard the horror
stories of data breaches.
The demise of many
retailers, a lot of it's
around they didn't
leverage their data.
And we all know,
everyone in this room
knows, we talk about
data constantly.
Data is the number one
strategic priority of marketers,
and especially retailers.
Data is that new currency.
It's the new oil.
It's the lifeblood
of the organization.
And if you don't really
have a handle on it,
you're not going
to be successful
in this current landscape.
Now, in advertising,
we often say,
not curing cancer and not making
the world safe for mankind,
we're just making ads.
Unlike physicians, marketers,
we don't take an oath.
But today, I want
us to take an oath.
As a marketer, the
oath I want you to take
is really critical and
it goes like this--
as a marketer, I vow to know
my customer, be my customer,
and empathize with my customer.
Those are the critical things
you must do as a marketer.
But of course, you might
be asking yourself,
where do I begin?
I've got lots of data.
Lots of siloed data.
I've got different
organizations,
different stakeholders.
I've got the finance person
breathing down my neck
going, what are you spending
all that marketing money on?
You've got lots of challenges
that you're facing.
So where do you begin?
The technology.
MATT MAGER: And traditionally
for marketers using Google,
that technology has been the
Google Marketing Platform.
That's been the
place where marketers
have gone to do the work
of knowing their customers
and empathizing
with them better.
But they haven't always
been called that.
So who here has used one
of these products before?
Lots of hands.
SHARON HARRIS: Raise them
high, raise them high.
MATT MAGER: Analytics,
DBM, now DV360, yes.
Keep your hands up if you
have used more than one
of these products.
Great.
So you know already,
and most of you
here have seen or
sit next to someone
who does, know that these
products have been loved
and used for years,
even though they
haven't been called the Google
Marketing Platform together.
Marketing analytics
products can already
share touch points and behaviors
in a privacy-positive way,
allowing brands to drive the
relevance that makes ads useful
and build the
relationships that users
need to ensure that the
brands stay top of mind.
The unified Google
Marketing Platform
is comprised of four
products along media buying,
ad serving, and
creative management,
and four analytics products on
tag management, site analytics,
data visualization, and
web page optimization.
This is the legacy Analytics
360 Suite and the DoubleClick
Platform.
Together these products make up
the Google Marketing Platform,
which is a really great place
to start to know and empathize
with your customers.
But the Google
Marketing Platform
is really only part
of the picture.
I mean, we're not at GML.
If we take the ads data and
the marketing data alone,
we can only do so much.
And for those of you
who are marketers,
you're probably doing as
much as you already can.
What we need to do is we
need to use the data that's
available to do more interesting
things, more in-depth things,
to know and to communicate
better with our customers.
Think about the
business challenges
you could solve if you added
your point of sale data
to your ad behavior.
Think about the questions that
your business is asking you
that you could answer if
you just had the CRM data
next to the ads impressions.
How much more can you know and
empathize with your customer
if you just have
more data connected?
We're now at a point where
CRM and offline data,
like point of sale,
are in places where
that can be leveraged faster.
Together with ads
and marketing data,
they can really help tell
both sides of the business
more things and help
them know and empathize
with your customers better.
The mark tech and
the ad tech side
obviously we'll get
a lot from this,
but in time the production and
supply chain side will too.
So Cloud and Google
Marketing Platform together
make it possible
to build better,
more impactful campaigns and
add vital data to your CRM.
This enables a better
personalization strategy,
keeping users engaged
and connected.
And that ensures that your
data is in a private and secure
place and is more thorough.
And of course, I
think it's great.
I work at Google.
But Sharon, from
your perspective,
why should marketers care
about Google Marketing Platform
and Google Cloud together?
SHARON HARRIS: Well,
Matt, it's super simple.
And it's simple for
everyone in this audience.
And we started with the why.
40% of all businesses
will die in 10 years.
The stakes are high.
So when you think
about the Google Cloud,
think about an open
and secure environment.
When it comes to privacy
and safety of consumer data,
you can't afford anything less.
And if you want to put your
business at risk because you've
chosen a platform that isn't
open, secure, and safe, good
luck.
Know the customer.
We took the oath.
Know customer, be the customer,
empathize with the customer.
Collecting and storing
data in the cloud
allows for faster analysis,
which really drives
your decision-making process.
Remember, you have hard dollars,
real investments on the line.
If you're not making the
right decisions and choices,
they can have catastrophic
consequences for your business
today.
Every second is precious
in this marketplace.
Third, machine learning.
Machine learning
gives you the ability
to solve very complex problems.
And ML is already a component
of the Google Cloud Platform.
So you can easily leverage
it to advance your marketing
capabilities.
And as a marketer
today, you really
want to be truly data-driven.
So leverage ML.
MATT MAGER: So what
does that look like?
For those of you who like
to look at architecture
and are pulling their phones
up now to take pictures of it,
you've probably seen
slides like this already.
We can bring in data from
the Google Marketing Platform
technologies, like Google
Analytics 360, Display & Video
360, and Google Ads like
YouTube and AdWords data.
This can all be stored
in BigQuery storage.
And with BigQuery Compute, you
can use Cloud Datalab and Cloud
ML to run SQL queries and
also to create clusters
for advanced segmentation.
In terms of
visualization, I think
it's really important
to note that all of us
don't look at tabular
data all the time.
It's really important
that, for those
who are making decisions who
aren't going to be actually
building out the data
sets, that they understand
what's actually happening.
So building out a visual
layer is really important.
SHARON HARRIS: Make it easy.
Make it easy for the marketer.
I already have a hard job.
I got 18 to 24 months
to show some results.
Help me make the
data work for me.
That's really the
key to visualization.
So I'm happy you're
doing that for me.
MATT MAGER: Right.
And Data Studio is awesome.
But some people like to
use Looker or Tableau.
Great tools.
And so the Google
Cloud Platform allows
you to create visuals using
any tool that you'd like.
For those of us on the Google
Marketing Platform side,
once you've built
out the clusters
that you're interested
in using, you
can push those in through what's
called data import into Google
Analytics 360 to run ads
on Display & Video 360
or across the Google Ads
products, like YouTube
or Search.
It's a really great way
to very easily leverage
what you've already
got and do things
that you can't do
inside of the user
interfaces of those products.
So on a high level,
a really easy example
of what we're doing
together with Deloitte today
looks like this.
We start with BigQuery.
We use the most
awesome, easy to use,
simple tons of
connections, BigQuery
to take all of the data
sources that we have
and put them together.
We add in the Display & Video
360 data using Data Transfer
files, as well as Google Ads
data from YouTube and AdWords.
And also, there's a
native BigQuery export
from Google Analytics 360
that allows you to put that
into BigQuery as well.
Now for the client that we have
that we're already doing this
with, they've got some data from
point of sales, transaction,
and customer databases
that they wanted to add in,
so we use DataPrep to
structure that in a way that
can sit alongside the ads data.
And then here's where
the magic happens.
Yes, you're pulling
up your phones again.
That's great.
We get two things out of this.
Once that data is
structured and put in a way
that we can use it, you
can get more analysis
and activation out of it.
And now for analysis,
it's important to note
that you can pass
the audiences back
into the tools for
measurement and visualization.
You can also just pull that into
a visualization tool itself.
And then for activation,
within the Google Ads products,
like DV360 and ads for
YouTube and Search,
it's possible to actually
activate across segments
that you've built that have
both the Display Video 360
data, the Google Ads data,
and also the behavioral data
from your site.
Again, this is a
very basic example,
even without getting into
machine learning or the AI
part.
SHARON HARRIS: Now show
them the real magic.
MATT MAGER: So this
is what people really
think that they need when
they first start, right?
It needs to be super complex.
It needs to solve
all my problems.
all of my challenges.
And every single
stakeholder, from the CEO
down to every
single coder, needs
to be in agreement
before we can do this.
This is something that
Deloitte has already
suggested to some clients.
And I think that we're
going to be building it out,
but it takes a long time to
get the stakeholders wrangled
together.
Empathy is really complicated
is what this says.
SHARON HARRIS: Very complicated.
So remember that, empathy
is very, very complicated.
MATT MAGER: But you really
can't start with this as a goal.
This is too big to sell into
all the stakeholders necessary.
So we've always
suggested that you
start with something simple,
high value, and scalable.
That way teams can
buy in on making
the project and the scope bigger
and more complex over time.
If you start with
that first slide,
you're going to scare
off a lot of people.
And we don't have time
to scare people off.
We need to bring them in.
SHARON HARRIS: And as
the manager and marketer,
you must prove value
with clear goals.
And you have to have quick wins.
Once again, you're really
up against the clock.
So you want to make sure
that what you're delivering
is going to really work.
So the construct
of test and learn
is the key to help
you close those gaps.
Now, we're going to take a look
at some examples of very, very
straightforward retail
client use cases.
And as the marker, there's
some frequent business problems
that you're trying to solve.
And we're always focused,
once again, what?
Know the customer,
be the customer,
empathize with the customer.
So these five are the
highest historical spenders
in your business.
Those online only shoppers,
you gotta love those folks.
Heavy browsers
that don't log in.
So you're not getting
any authenticated data.
Heavy couponers.
How many people love coupons?
Show of hands.
That's it?
Nobody likes to save money?
Come on, get on the
coupon bandwagon.
My favorite is loyal customers
that buy in-store and online.
I have to raise my hand
really high for that one
because that is me
all day every day.
You too?
I knew it.
So as we think about
these use cases,
these are really core
to the retail space.
And as we go through this,
we're to really focus on two.
And the first, which is really
a foundational use case.
This is all about,
how do you unlock
the data that you have so that
you can start to control it.
You can start to leverage it.
You can start to really
use it in your business.
This is a critical
step in the journey.
You really can't go
forward unless you
have this foundation
built. And this
is all about building an
advanced data infrastructure
for media insights.
As the marketer,
you're always asked,
am I getting the value out of
my media spin that I should?
Am I reaching the
right audience?
Am I reaching them at
the right frequency?
Is it with the right message?
Who knows.
And sometimes you really
can't ask your agency.
So what can you do
to really understand
the performance of it?
So Matt, tell us what do we do.
MATT MAGER: Well, I can
tell you what you've done.
Deloitte has done this
for marketing already
using Data Transfer files
from Display & Video 360.
They're using BigQuery, and
R, and data visualizations,
and business intelligence
tools to derive detailed media
analytics.
So what they've done is they've
taken those Data Transfer files
and they've done with them
more granular insights than you
can get from the user
interfaces of those tools alone.
And then looking at
that granular data,
they have the ability
to more accurately look
at media metrics, including
reach and frequency.
This seems like a base
case because it is.
Again, we wanted to
start with something
simple, scalable, and of
high value because this
provides the infrastructure
to deliver advanced media
insights.
So again, we're
suggesting for you
to start with something
simple and foundational.
SHARON HARRIS: Prove your case.
Bring people over.
That's really critical.
MATT MAGER: And
so the value that
is derived from
doing this, as you're
traveling from the left side to
the right side, data comes in
and it's unstructured.
Or it's structured,
but not in a way
that's congruous with the rest
of the data that you have.
And as we provide more and more
structure and more and more
details emerge, we can start
to get more and more insights.
So things like understanding
cross campaign conversion
and user overlap
is kind of basic.
But as you get a quick win, you
get more teams bought into it.
And then you can start
doing more advanced things,
like trending, analytics,
and visualizations
off of what you've
already built.
And then starting to get into
predictive analytics, customer
lifetime value, churn
propensity, et cetera.
And then you get to start
doing activation at scale.
The true goal here is to be able
to do things quickly, scalably,
and automated, if you can.
Again, this is the base
case for really anything,
including our second use case.
SHARON HARRIS: Which is all
about data-driven segmentation.
Now when you think of
data-driven segmentation,
as the marketer, yes, you
want to know your customer.
But you need to know, is
this a loyal customer?
Is this a new customer?
You want understand, can
I discover new customers?
Because that's ultimately
the real prize.
And when we segment and
categorize customers,
that really drives our
decision-making process.
And it ultimately leads to
greater efficiencies, which
give you stronger returns.
So Matt, once again, how are
we going to pull this off?
MATT MAGER: So if you
remember that old slide,
collect, cluster,
visualize, and activate.
It's almost the same story.
But what we can
do is we can take
that point of sale data, along
with site analytics and CRM
data, and run machine
learning clusters on it
to find meaningful
behavioral insights.
So identifying user
attributes of each cluster
that, when users show up
and behave in certain ways,
that we can then
put them quickly
into a segment that
might be able to be
activated or at least
be visualized so we
can start looking at trends.
And then finally,
activating those clusters
when possible for media
buying on Display & Video 360,
Google Ads, or other
media channels.
So let's look at an example
of how we might apply that
to an actual user situation.
And because it was
just her birthday,
we've named my hypothetical
user on my mom, Audrey.
SHARON HARRIS: Unfortunately we
couldn't bring Audrey with us
today, but she is here
with us in spirit,
cheering her beautiful
son, Matt, on.
MATT MAGER: It would be a much
longer session if she was here.
Anyway.
So we're going to say
that Audrey just went
online, and went to an
electronics retailer,
and bought a camera.
Now she might shop at that
electronics retailer online
pretty often, so we might
have some CRM data about her,
and we have GA360 purchase data,
and maybe some behavioral data.
So we have some
insights already.
Now with Display & Video 360, or
with other activation channels,
we could do things like sending
her ads for the accessories
that she might need
for that camera,
or suggesting that she
bundle together memory cards.
But that's kind
of all we can do.
Let's say, things related
to exactly what you're
doing right now.
But if we're adding things
like machine learning tools
across our entire CRM and across
all of the behavioral insights
that we can pull, we can
cluster Audrey, or my mom,
into a group of people who
are frequent travelers.
So we start getting
insights about people
who have bought cameras,
but have also bought
things like
international chargers
or lots of different cords for
things because they lose them.
And we know that people
who are frequent travelers
don't just buy cameras.
They also buy noise
canceling headphones.
Who has noise canceling
headphones who travels a lot?
Yeah, exactly.
That kid in the fourth row.
You know who I'm talking about.
Anyway, so the reason
that that's important
is because then we can
start segmenting out
users who have done
some of the things
that we're interested
in, but not all of them.
So we take this user, Audrey.
We start to cluster
users like her
that have done things
like bought a camera,
are identified as a
frequent traveler,
but haven't bought
those headphones.
And then we can tailor
ads to those people
specifically, like showing
them ads specific to,
you're a frequent
traveler, Audrey.
We know you bought this camera
and here's some headphones
you might want, too.
Audrey sees an ad.
She has a higher likelihood
of buying those headphones
before her next trip.
SHARON HARRIS: Or if
you're a really good son,
Mother's Day is approaching.
Sounds like a good gift for mom.
MATT MAGER: I want her
to hear when I call.
So today we've walked through
architecture and examples
of two really
important use cases
to bring together Google Cloud
and Google Marketing Platforms
to help you know and empathize
with the people who matter
to you most, your customers.
The better together
story is about doing
that at the pace of change of
the industry, your business,
and the people who are buying
you and keeping you alive.
SHARON HARRIS: Without a doubt.
We hope the information
that we shared today
from the perspective of
a marketer, and retail,
and of course the
technologist, have somehow
been enlightening to you.
I absolutely love technology.
But what I love more is what
a technology allows me to do.
I like it to be actually
seamless and in the background,
because I want to be
the person in control.
And for marketers, and
especially retailers,
Google Cloud gives you
that speed, and privacy,
and security to do what?
Know your customer,
be your customer,
empathize with your customer.
Secondly, predict
marketing outcomes.
You want to know where
the puck is going.
You don't want to
be where it is.
You want to be ahead
of those trends.
And as a retailer
and a marketer,
whatever your product is, you
need to have that ability.
So you can harness the
technology to help you do that.
And then thirdly,
personalized experiences.
Consumers are demanding more
and more personalization.
We want ads, products,
and experiences
that are relevant to
us, that speak to us.
That's really critical.
So if you don't
take anything away
from what we've
talked about today,
take away these
three things when you
think about the Google Cloud.
Know your customer, predict
those marketing outcomes,
and personalize
those experiences
on a platform that gives
you greater speed, privacy,
and security.
Now, we've empowered all of
you with this great information
so you can be change agents
in your organization.
And that's not a difficult task.
Change is always
hard, but it all
begins with something
very simple.
It's called the conversation.
You know it's always like when
your significant other says,
we need to talk.
Let's have a talk
or a conversation.
Those things can be challenging.
But for an organization,
the biggest hurdle
is really around
shifting mindset.
Evolving the culture
of the organization
can sometimes be your
number one obstacle.
Having those conversations
early and often is really key,
because you've really
got to work to break down
the silos, in marketing,
in technology, in sales,
in operations, and finance,
because ultimately,
every single aspect
of the business
is made better when
you come together.
MATT MAGER: And
if you don't, it's
kind of clear what's
going to happen.
SHARON HARRIS: Exactly.
But there is hope.
If we think about the brands,
like the Sears, and the Toys R
Uses, of the world,
what they could
have done with their data.
Had they used these
kinds of technologies
or if they had been
available to them,
we may not have to say
goodbye to Jeffrey.
You know?
Think about it.
Those are real,
real consequences
of when you're not
leveraging the technology.
MATT MAGER: And the
other thing that
goes kind of without
saying is that we
need partners, and
marketers, and Google,
and other ecosystem players
involved to get this done.
We need especially
strong partners
to be able to help marketers
through these challenges,
both through the
communication part of it
and the delivery itself.
That slide, the really
complicated one,
very few marketers can
do that by themselves.
Some can, but very
few can do it.
So we need partners
that are really
enabled and able to do this.
And I want to say thank
you to you, Sharon,
for being such a great partner.
SHARON HARRIS: And
thank you to Matt
for being my technologist
extraordinaire at Google.
But we hope you've
enjoyed this presentation.
We knew it was the
end of the day,
so we weren't going to keep
you the entire 50-plus minutes,
because we're standing probably
between food, cocktails, music,
what have you.
But we hope that you
found this valuable.
And we're happy to
take your questions.
And you know, both Deloitte
and Google are here to help.
But before you exit, we do
have something to ask of you--
your feedback.
Complete the survey
session in the mobile app.
And of course, as
Matt shamelessly says,
five stars is always
better than one.
But we would love
to hear from you.
So if anyone's
got any questions.
MATT MAGER: Yep, there are a
couple of microphones here.
And I know that we don't have
anything on the Dory right now.
Thank you so much
for your time today.
AUDIENCE: I got a question.
I was curious about what
Google, what type of tools
you guys provide to enable
marketer to run experiments.
MATT MAGER: I'm sorry,
can you repeat that?
AUDIENCE: What kind
of tools do you
have to enable a marketing
team to run experiments?
To understand the customers,
you need to run experiments.
MATT MAGER: So
there are a couple
of different kind of
experiments that you
might be talking about.
And some are on the website.
So if it's a web experiment,
there's Optimize 360.
There is a free version
of Optimize, as well.
You can take a look at that.
That can actually, if you're
using the Google Analytics 360
product, you can take audiences
directly from Google Analytics
and push those into
Optimize 360 for tests.
It's a really great product.
It's not as used as some of
the other GA360 Suite products,
but it's really excellent.
I suggest you try it.
In terms of other
testing scenarios,
there are some within
the Ads products.
And you'd have to ask
someone within cloud
who can give you more.
AUDIENCE: Just to
follow up on that.
Do you have any optimization
tools across channels?
Not just the [? optimizer ?]
[INAUDIBLE] apps.
Do you have some sort of
cross-channel optimization
tools?
That's basically
what I'm asking for.
MATT MAGER: So
currently, I'm not
aware of a cross-channel
optimization tool.
There were some technologies
within the Attribution 360 tool
originally that were
slated to do that,
but that is not currently
an available product.
AUDIENCE: This is
a general question.
And I wondered if you could
talk a bit about how you think
privacy and the
interests of customers
in terms of having more privacy
or maybe control of their data
and how that might affect
the marketing ecosystem.
SHARON HARRIS: Oh sure.
I mean, privacy is a hot topic.
I think first and
foremost as a marketer,
you need to understand consent.
Consumer consent is everything.
So if you're collecting
data, and it's
important to have your
own first party data,
make sure you have
the right consent.
That's going to be key.
And then, once again, it
needs to be first party data.
We talk a lot about
data breaches.
And a lot of that
stems from the fact
that many marketers
and many brands
don't really own their own data.
They've got their data siloed.
It's across different platforms.
They've got different
agencies in there.
So they don't really
have great visibility
nor transparency into
what's happening.
But there are a couple
of things that I really
stress to people today.
Pay attention to
the regulations.
We already have GDPR in Europe.
We have CCPA, or the California
Consumer Protection Act,
that's about to
be ratified here.
Those are really going to
be game changers for how
you think about the collection
and storage of data.
So first party data
is really critical.
And because if
you don't have it,
the penalties for
those data breaches
are not just the loss
of your customers,
but also some
pretty hefty fines.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very
much for your speech.
As far as I know, user ID is
unavailable on Data Transfer
files from DoubleClick.
MATT MAGER: That's correct.
AUDIENCE: Yep.
So did you make this case before
those limitations [INAUDIBLE]??
MATT MAGER: Thank you.
For those of you
who are not aware,
Data Transfer files, as we've
described, from the Display
& Video 360 product
and Campaign Manager
product do not include user ID.
So the full cookie
stream information.
However, that
information can be used.
Not necessarily joined
directly to the GA 360 data,
but also things
like time stamping
or other predictive cases can
allow you to still get insights
from.
There is also an
additional product set
that could potentially solve
some problems or questions
about Data Transfer files that
are missing user ID fields.
And that's something that you
should talk to your Google team
about.
SHARON HARRIS: One
more there in the back.
MATT MAGER: One more?
Oh, Hi Jack.
JACK: Hi, Matt.
Matt, Sharon, thanks
very much, first of all,
for sharing all this.
Very helpful.
I really appreciate
the fact that this
might be one of
the first examples
I've seen where Google Cloud
Platform is being illustrated
as an integral part
of the solution
that the Google Marketing
Platform can deliver.
So congratulations on the
One Google theme here.
It's also affirming to show
that disparate data can
be consolidated to
create better audiences.
My question is, will we
be seeing more of that?
Will we be seeing more of One
Google, where the Google Cloud
Platform becomes a
foundation for the great work
that you guys do
on the GMP side?
MATT MAGER: I think it's pretty
safe to say that yes, we'll
be seeing more of that.
What that will look like from
day to day, quarter to quarter,
year to year may change.
But I think everyone
on both the clouds
and the GMP side know
that we need each other
to be able to answer the
fundamental questions
and challenges that
marketers have today.
JACK: Good.
Looking forward to seeing it.
Thank you.
MATT MAGER: Well,
thank you very much,
everyone, for coming today.
Thank you, Sharon.
SHARON HARRIS: Thank you.
Enjoy the rest of
your Cloud Next.